quand on a dit vous savez il y a des
biais il y a des conflits d'intérêts qui
me sont absolument pas déclarés il y a
des gens qui touchent à la fois de
l'argent moi le premier c'est pour ça
que ça a commencé très vite dès que j'ai
commencé par parler de la cloquine j'ai
reçu des coups de téléphone à donner
dans le cheminant ils sont plus anonymes
c'est le professeur Raffi de Nantes qui
m'appelait on l'a identifié grâce à la
police il a été condamné on peut le dire
et c'est lui le téléphone la nuit à
minuit et donc pour me menacer donc le
le c'est celui qui était le numéro 1 de
tous les financements il avait reçu
600000 euros de l'industrie
pharmaceutique les six dernières années
c'est le numéro 1 après vous pouvez
toujours dire vous êtes complotiste
c'est possible qu'il y a un lien ou
c'est faut-il que soit une coïncidence
soyez mais c'est c'est ça amène à
réfléchir sur le fait est-ce que c'est
vraiment la recherche médicale de
fournir des malades à des programmes
écrits par l'industrie pharmaceutique
dont les données ne sont analysées que
par l'industrie pharmaceutique qui fait
écrire ça parce qu'on appelle les
gaufres acteurs c'est-à-dire des
écrivains professionnels et qui sont
accepter à l'avance par les plus grands
journaux parce qu'on sait que ça va
rapporter un argent fou aux journaux
même qu'il est publie donc pour vous
c'est un grand complot
c'est pas du tout c'est une évolution de
la société auquel nous ne sommes pas
préparés il y a plusieurs éléments
les gens ont pas l'habitude qu'une
molécule puisse servir à plus d'une
chose c'est un point et donc les seuls
qui vraiment est travaillé là-dessus
nous on a un peu travaillé dessus mais
c'est beaucoup les Chinois si vous
voulez ils ont ils ont pris toutes les
molécules qui sont considérées comme non
toxiques par la FDA c'est qu'elle
équivalent de l'entrée NSM pour les
tester sur le covid ils ont trouvé 20
molécules qui n'ont strictement rien à
voir avec les antiviraux qui sont
efficaces donc des antidépresseurs dont
un antiparkinsonien après on s'est rendu
compte que les gens qui avaient les
Parkinson faisaient les formes moins
graves ou pas de covid et en réalité
c'est parce que un des médicaments qu'on
donne pour la maladie de Parkinson est
un médicament qui a une activité contre
le virus si on teste l'activité sur le
il y a des neuroleptiques qui ont une
activité sur le virus donc l'idée que
chaque molécule a une activité unique
qui est juste celle pourquoi on l'a
testé au départ c'est un fantasme c'est
pas vrai donc celle dont on sait au
départ qu'elles ne sont pas toxiques
parce qu'on les utilise depuis 20 30 40
ans qui ne coûte pas cher parce que
comme elles ont plus de 20 ans elles
sont plus protégées par des brevets si
celles qui devrait en priorité nous
intéresser par exemple
on a regardé on a retrouvé des travaux
pour ça quand on dit il y a une très
grande résistance des bactéries aux
antibiotiques nous on a testé
effectivement les 2500 molécules qui qui
sont non toxiques et parmi celles-là on
a redécouvert que l'azé.t qui était le
premier médicament qu'on donnait dans le
sida et à merveilleux antibiotique
contre échashevoli ce que tout le monde
avait oublié et que personne ne veut va
reconversialiser ça rapporte rien donc
si vous voulez il y a il y a on se
heurte là si on fait passer une idée de
cette nature là j'ai pas vu rendez
compte des enjeux financiers monstrueux
mais pour tout le monde pour l'industrie
pour les journaux scientifiques
aux gens qui se dit ah oui il a la
grosse tête ou leur dites quoi
une taille de chapeau régulière
[Musique]
parce que ça se passe très bien avec
nous mais il y en a ceux qui disent ça
qui c'est quoi c'est une manière de vous
attaquer c'est quoi
leur demander à eux ce qu'ils entendent
c'est quoi votre relation avec Emmanuel
Macron maintenant on a beaucoup parlé de
votre relation avec le président de la
République un coup vous étiez fâché un
coup il vous consultez tous les jours un
coup vous dormiez chez lui un coup il
dormait dans un lit superposé ok c'est
quoi la vérité
[Musique]
si vous voulez je peux pas dire que j'ai
été convaincu par le l'enthousiasme de
la vaccination généralisée dont je pense
qu'elle n'était pas on a voulu pour ça
j'en sais rien mais en tout cas
je vous rappelais ce que je disais j'ai
attend défaut prudemment là parce que il
y avait au moins trois raisons qui
laissaient pensé que
ça ne marcherait pas comment on
prédisait que ça marcherait c'est que il
y a aucun vaccin qui marche pour les
infections virales respiratoire zéro
aussi ça marchait on aurait pu de grippe
depuis longtemps donc si ça marche pas
pour la grippe tous les ans c'est parce
qu'il y a un problème d'accord
deuxièmement moi j'ai su un peu plus tôt
que les autres que ce virus mutait très
très rapidement ce qui était l'inverse
de ce qu'on pensait sur les coronavirus
pour des raisons techniques sur lequel
je veux pas m'étendre mais la véritable
pandémie a commencé en Italie parce
qu'il y a eu deux mutations qui sont
passées une
mutation dans la machine à reproduire le
virus qui a fait qui fait 100 fois plus
d'erreurs que tous les autres
coronavirus ne font et c'est 100 fois
plus d'erreur c'est ce qui explique tous
ces variants donc là tous ceux qui vont
faire le rappel du vaccin pour vous
c'est inutile
je sais pas si c'est une petite toute
manière tous les vaccins pour tous les
vaccins et les questions de et pour
toutes les actions médicales que l'on a
pour les patients c'est de faire la
balance entre le bénéfice et le risque
si vous n'avez aucun risque si vous
voulez vous n'avez aucun bénéfice à
espérer donc il y a une étude
indépendamment d'un autre on trouve la
même chose des Suédois très complètes
très carré comme les Scandinaves sur
10000 personnes de moins de 45 ans qui
font la maladie il y a un mort d'accord
donc et pendant la période d'observation
il y avait 10% de gens qui ont la
maladie donc ce qui veut dire que chez
les moins de 45 ans il y avait un mort
sur 100 000 donc vous pouvez pas évaluer
un vaccin permettant de montrer qu'il y
a moins d'un mort sur 100 000 c'est pas
possible il faudrait que vous en testiez
un million avant donc mais en revanche
comme la moitié des gens qui sont morts
en plus de 85 ans si vous vaccinez les
jambes plus de 85 ans vous faites pas
quelque chose de fou quand même vous
faites quelque chose et nous on voit
qu'effectivement chez les gens sont très
à risque puis 75 ans toujours dans notre
série de 30000 personnes le vaccin a un
effet protecteur chez Jean plus de 75
ans de de de des deux tiers il y a deux
fois il y a un tiers de gens qui vont
faire des formes mortelles
il est pas il est pas positif quoi voilà
il est pas il a surtout on sait que nous
on a su ça très tôt on sait que il peut
y avoir des porteurs sains dans le même
nombre dans le même pourcentage et les
vaccinés et non vaccinés